hey guys it is Friday which means I've
got five of the biggest things that
happened in gaming this week all ready
to go for you and yes I do a lot of all
that stuff hang in there nonetheless and
Xbox have playfully bitten back at Sony
in a new video that shows up how easy
backwards compatibility is to use after
so need massive job at Microsoft at e3
2013 over its now reverse to use games
policy Microsoft now have their own
score on the board so he isn't mentioned
by name but some people believe that
xbox appeared to be specifically
reacting to the PlayStation game trading
instructional video which explained how
to share games by simply handing the
disk to your friend in the Xbox video
the Xbox UK team highlights the
simplicity of loading up games the fact
that you don't need to subscribe and
that the entire service is free
a game-breaking bugs have been
discovered in fallout 4 sir vault
dwellers beware apparently the bug is
related to a settlement quest at
Monsignor Plaza upon traveling there
several players encountered a crash to
desktop with no error message the
buggers are broadly affected users on
ps4 xbox one and pc anyone who's playing
fallout 4 on any platform can probably
tell you the game is littered with bugs
but this is one of the first discovered
to actually break your game there's no
official word or fix from Bethesda at
this point thanks to the super
perception powers of the internet we may
know the name of Mass Effect Andromeda's
protagonist reddit user ballito spotted
a dog tag in the recent and seven day
trailer which seemed to read rider given
Shepherd was named after alan shepard
the first American man in space and the
name of the first American woman in
space was Sally Ride we could be onto
something here another clue may lie in
the musical track used for Andromeda's
announcement trailer which was Johnny
Cash's rendition of ghost riders in the
sky the evidence is piling up but no
official word from bioware at this stage
whether you love or hate PewDiePie
there's no doubting his popularity and
your next spectacle is on the way as a
YouTube red subscriber-only show called
scare PewDiePie some mega famous
youtuber who is known for playing creepy
games and screaming is now going to be
put in real life for a situation
inspired by now is very games our first
live show PewDiePie trapped in a little
box approached by a man brandishing a
sight and getting covered in goo you
know your typical horror elements the
show's described as part prank show part
suspense adventure and it's co-produced
by The Walking Dead production company
skybound entertainment and Disney's
making studios it will air as premium
content for YouTube red subscribers next
year and in my favorite story of the
week gaming or at least fallout 4
appears to be more appealing than porn
according to the adult website pornhub
the release of blood for led to a fairly
significant ten percent drop in their
traffic they released several graphs
depicting the traffic change and
suggested that while people appeared to
be on the site while their game was
installing many left to attend to the
wasteland at around five a.m. to 12noon
pornhub noted a second drop when workers
arrived home around six pm and seemingly
booted up their flat for game rather
than there incognito browser window let
me know down in the comments what you
cared about this week and what bugs
you've come across in fallout 4 so far
this week on site I talked about some of
the most epic moments from tomb raider
on the chest we review star wars
battlefront and try
call of duty brands at DIA that is
everything I have this week so as always
have yourselves a wonderful weekend and
I will catch you again on Monday